hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so in this video we're going
to be talking about
okay our matrices in a quick tip for
remembering the matrices that rotate and
reflect and a lot of students that I
work with they get a little bit confused
because they say we know there's all
these matrices how do I remember which
one does which and I'm going to show you
a little tip for figuring that out and
so you don't have to memorize as much so
we're going to be taking a look at are
these two points here point number one
and point number two point number one is
one zero and point number two is zero
one and if we make a matrix like this
one zero zero one this is point number
one and this is point number two so
there the coordinates are written
vertically okay as you can see here 1 0
and 0 1 and if you notice this is the
identity matrix the identity matrix
means that if you multiply this times
another matrix okay it's going to give
that matrix back so it's just like
multiplying by the number 1 anything
times 1 gives you itself back same thing
with the identity matrix and what we're
going to do now is we're going to look
at how does this matrix change as you
rotate 90 degrees 180 270 and if you
reflect over the x-axis y-axis or the
line y equals x it's very easy all you
do is pay attention to these two points
if we want to remember the matrix that
rotates 90 degrees we look at what
happens to 0.1 and 2 when we rotate 90
so if we rotate 90 okay look what
happens point 1 0 moves to 0 1 so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to replace
0.1 here with its new coordinates 2 0 1
point number 2 0 1 it's going to move to
this point over here which is negative 1
0 so this matrix is going to be the
matrix we want if we want to rotate 90
degrees ok let's look at 180 so if you
rotate 180 this point is going to move
half a rotation over to here which is
going to put us at negative 1 0 where as
point number 2 is going to rotate all
the way down to here and that's a
coordinate it's going to be 0 negative 1
so by multiplying by this matrix you're
going to be able to rotate you know
preimage to its image
degrees if you rotate 270 at this point
here is going to rotate 3/4 of a turn
it's going to end up at 0 negative 1 and
this point 0 1 is going to rotate 3/4 of
a turn it will be at 1 0 now if you
reflect over the x-axis we're folding it
over the x-axis the mirror image this
point is actually on the line of
reflection so it's going to stay right
where it's at 1 0 whereas this point is
going to reflect down there at 0
negative 1 so here with me so far if we
reflect over the y-axis this point is
going to reflect over here it's going to
be at 0 whoops I'm sorry negative 1 0
and then this point is on the line of
reflection so it's going to stay where
it's at at 0 1 and then the line y
equals x that's this 45-degree line here
this point is going to be where point 2
is point 2 is gonna be where point 1 is
they're actually going to interchange
positions so that's going to be 0 1 and
1 0 and just to give you a quick example
like say for example you just want to
take a point 3 1 like this and you want
to you know reflected over the line y
equals x well all you would have to do
is multiply this matrix times the point
3 1 and you multiply rows times columns
so that gives you what 0 times 3 is 0 1
times 1 is 1 and we add those together
and then the second row first column you
get 3 plus 0 which is 3 so you can see
the X and the y coordinates have
actually interchanged and that's exactly
what happens when you reflect over line
y equals x but this is how you would
remember all the different matrices that
perform some of these reflecting and
rotating operations so I hope this video
helped you to understand a little bit
better go ahead and subscribe to the
channel check out some of my other
videos about matrices and I look forward
to seeing in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon